pourquoi la prison de guantanamo n'a
toujours pas été fermé ça c'est la
grosse question quand la guerre a été
déclarée par les américains contre les
terroristes contre à l'époque ben laden
puis ensuite al qaïda quand ils
arrêtaient les terroristes ils ne les
ramenez pas sur le territoire américain
parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas à ce
moment là faire tout ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est à dire qu'on les a emmenés dans
des prisons secrètes un peu partout dans
le monde puis ensuite d'ailleurs à
guantanamo où les gens étaient torturés
et être été traités dans des conditions
épouvantables qui rappellent pourquoi
pour nous français les conditions dans
lesquelles les nazis traiter les
résistants en france et c'est pas une
comparaison entre les terroristes et les
résistants et sur le plan du traitement
des êtres humains
on savait qu'il y avait peu ce côté là
les américains dont ont profité de
bandanas mots
aujourd'hui si on fait un grand un
hameau il faut rapatrier sur le sol
américain un certain nombre de gens qui
sont toujours en prison à guantanamo
avec tout ce que ça va comporter comme
problème par rapport à la loi américaine
et à la protection des individus sur le
sol américain donc c'est pour ça que
depuis vingt ans devant face à ce
problème eh bien les américains ne ferme
pas mentalement
[Musique]